si vous vous promenez le matin dans les
environs d'ermenonville vous risquez
fort d'y rencontrer ce bien curieux
équipage ne vous étonnez pas il s'agit
simplement de marionnaud atchik 32 ans
cascadeur qui a connu des milieux
cinématographiques qui centre
élève de claude carrière bernard celeron
et début de roseville mariolo ouachi a
accepté d'évoquer pour 30 millions
d'amis par une spectaculaire
démonstration les liens qui l'unissent à
ses cheveux
à
je pense qu'un cheval qui fait du cinéma
ou qui fait de la cascade qui fait de la
voltige ou qui fait toutes ces choses de
la plage réagit mieux je pense qu'un
cheval de clubs qui s'ennuient qui
change sans arrêt de maître qui ne
voient pas ils voyaient à l'infini
l'autre commence c'est toujours le même
train autour noront est tout tandis que
là là on a quelque chose de spécial on
lui demande de s'occuper
on lui demande de s'intéresser à ce qui
fait ici intéresse énormément comme un
fou parce que souvent moi j'ai vu faire
des erreurs d'inattention et que ce sont
de cheval qui me rattrape
vous êtes complices
heureusement je pourrais pas faire la
cascade je n'étais pas complice avec mes
choix il faut qu'il m'aide et il met
d'ailleurs dans beaucoup de choses parce
qu'il ya des fois où vous êtes donc
difficulté ça m'est déjà arrivé par
exemple voltige d'être avec par exemple
ce cheval à un soir je m'entraînais dans
un an ça chôme donc c'est vraiment la
grande grande plaine direction chez moi
parce que je me suis comme il était un
peu fatigué je me suis dit tiens là il
va il va y aller comme un fou et d'un
seul coup je démarre sur un mouvement en
pensant à un autre mouvement et mes
mains sont recroise résultats jetables
par terre mais je ne suis jamais remonté
sur le chemin je suis parti sur la
gueule c'est un cheval est parti plus
droit là j'ai poussé un énorme cri un
nom pas de peur mais parce que je voyais
que je fais là vais rentrer à toute
vitesse à la maison le cheval s'est
arrêtée immédiatement et s'est retourné
en me regardant vraiment comme pour dire
mais il est complètement ridicule
pourquoi il se casse la figure
d'habitude ça n'arrive pas et il m'a
attendu tranquillement
aussi incroyable que ça puisse paraître
est pourtant en direction de la maison
certains cavaliers doivent parfaitement
savoir que dans ce qui des choses
direction mon écurie jamais le cheval
s'arrête
c'est extrêmement rare que le cheval ou
fasse une petite entourloupe être des
choses comme ça au contraire même je
dirais plutôt qu'ils jouent sur le côté
extrêmement cabot de la chose lorsqu'ils
rentrent en dise les applaudissements
les bruits des caméras les lumières moi
je sens que mes chevaux change du tout
au tout je vais faire une première dans
forêts je sens parfaitement qu'ils
s'ennuient ils se demandent ils sont là
ils principes édictés affiche 10 bon ben
ça on est chaud maintenant qu'on va
commencer le travail
ils attendent le départ du travail
allant se déroule une préparation avant
pour préparer une cascade
il figure au petit à petit on amène le
schale petit à petit à la chose surtout
que ça nuit lui apporte absolument pas
de peur ni de crainte à st
et donc pour cela la seule chose qui
peut faire peur un à cheval c'est
lorsqu'il se fait mal et nous nous
employons parfaitement bien ce qui ne se
passe jamais mal parce que je préfère me
faire mal mort parce que c'est pas trop
grave je me réparer je sais pourquoi je
me suis pas mal même cheval ne sait pas
lui alors ce que je vais lui demander de
retourner dans l'action si c'était
valais ne sera plus jamais retourner
c'est légitime
et voilà le travail
le cheval n'a rien comme vous pouvez
voir le cheval est absolument rien il
sait parfaitement bien ce stick de sud
se pratique justement exprès pour que ce
rsa merveilleusement regrouper pour
pouvoir culbuter parfaitement bien
déroulée c'est pas comme par exemple une
chute de faux sûr je conseille avant que
les chutes de pouce était mieux parce
que ça permettait aux jeunes de
descendre comme ça mais en fin de compte
non lorsqu'on lui regroupe bien les
intérieurs l'échelle fait un roulé boulé
exactement comme moi
en fin de compte le plus difficile c'est
presque moi parce que moi je n'arrive
plus à plat que le fait drôle
m
pas plus
on
les chevaux sont cascadeur aussi une
allemande diana j'ai un cheval blanc qui
est en tête de la poste on voit qui est
à cheval alors sauf facilement 2 5
mètres dans le vide dans l'eau passe à
travers les flammes
il ya des chevaux quand même qu'ils ont
un côté très très faussaires il y en a
d'autres qui ont peur de tout
alertant ainsi la voile
oui on peut obtenir 15 salsa soit
parfaitement bien exactement comme un
chien c'est une des choses je pense les
plus difficiles à obtenir nash face
parce que généralement les gens le
couche et le bloc au moment où il veut
se relever tandis que laval vraiment le
cheval s'installe tranquillement
lui-même et restent assis et pu rester
très très longtemps en place
en plaçant oil
généralement ce sont tous des andalous
des arabes ou croisement espano arabe ou
easy tone aux arabes se sont seulement
ses chevaux la joue pas taire parce
qu'ils ont du coeur sont calmes où là
c'est toute l'énergie qu'ils le
dépensent ils l'avaient pense rarement
contre vous la dépense pour travailler
mais rarement pour créer des problèmes
et non pas du tout ce que tu étais tu de
la chose du sel française ou du pur-sang
lunatique des changements avec beaucoup
d'humour la nôtre du coup c'est toujours
égal à lui-même où il me fait le
problème parce qu'ils se défendent
mais là ce qu'il a accepté il a fait
totalement c'est ce qui est très
agréable dans cette phase
qui
aujourd'hui j'aime le cheval pour le
cheval j'aime tout ce qui est difficile
longue cheval comme la poste hongroise
connu l'attelage aimerait fins de
championnats du monde d'attelage ça
c'est une chose qui me trotte énormément
la tête mais le problème c'est l'argent
cette chose même si vous avez des
capacités si vous n'avez pas les moyens
ne pouvait pas arriver à faire quelque
chose comme ça parce que ça demande
énormément
et maintenant on peut travailler à
cheval alors ça ça dépend énormément de
l'entraînement que vous lui avez donné
auparavant et de la nourriture que vous
lui donnez moi j'ai déjà travaillé huit
heures d'affilée avec des cheveux très
très dur et les chemins ont été
entraînées pourrai manger une très
grande quantité d'avoine et là ils
tiennent parfaitement choc dans le temps
et relève d'une urgence faisait
facilement 17 kilomètres donc est tous
passé le ballon et jusqu'à quel âge pas
vaillant cheval dans votre métier parce
que ça dépend beaucoup de son maître si
son maître l'utilisent avec intelligence
il peut durer 15 à 20 ans 620 km on
utilise en comme ça très fort comme on
fait des grands coups d'accélérateur m
battu en des choses comme ça ça me
désole me comparer à un karim voiture
mais enfin si on fait la même chose que
ce qui les condamne même se fait sur
l'utilisateur gmail comme uri en
conséquence h elle peut durer vingt ans
est-ce qu'il est aussi le héros du
cinéma l'oustal plus que ferait gary
cooper sur son cheval que ferrero et
rodgers empêchera sinon rien que
serait-il ce serait quelqu'un vous voyez
un petit peu l'air ridicule que pour
avoir les rodgers marchepied cause avant
courant dans la plaine et tout vaut
mieux qu'ils soient à cheval moi je
crois que vous avez le héros qui est 40%
et dresse le cheval sont les belles
poursuites de diligence sans les grandes
gueules par les attaques des indiens
cheval et que ferions nous
rien ce serait vraiment plat luis terme
en tout cas avec lui en plus la preuve
de l'importance chan dans le western
c'est que vous êtes acquis une banque on
vous condamnez à certaines allées prison
vendredi un cheval on s'attendait
lorsque dans une année j'estime que mes
cheveux ont gagné de quoi se nourrir eux
mêmes
je trouve ça parfait pour moi c'est une
excellente année 13 mai les chenaux ne
faut pas vivre parce qu'il suffit que
vous ayez une seule semaine d'arrêt du
cheval pour qu'immédiatement il ne gagne
plus haut pitance et donc c'est vous
avec le travail que vous faites dans les
autres cascades vous êtes obligé de
donner la pitance aux femmes c'est un
choix difficile mais pour le projet pour
moi c'est ma passion donc comme les gens
achètent des timbres moi je souhaite de
la nourriture pour mes chevaux sauf que
les timbres rapporte un futur des choix
pas toujours sont heureux les
pourparlers ou donc enfin vu l'état dans
lequel vous pouvez regarder mes chevaux
ils sont tous dans un excellent en
détail son bocal il déborde plutôt de
muscles que d'autres choses donc je
pense qu'ils sont tombés comptant sept
prochains mois oui enfin parfaitement
mon moi je peux parler je peux vous le
dire de ce côté là où il a fait ce
qu'ils vous ont apporté
je vais dire un mot qui ne sont
peut-être pas la télévision un pif
antastique des dizaines de pied
exceptionnel parce que je crois que
c'est vraiment la chose la plus ça n'a
rien à voir avec une maj c'est vivant
c'est quelque chose de vivant ça explose
ça bouge un par moments c'est pas du
tout d'accord ça réagit voulant que les
vous l'appelez ça revient il écoute
voyez les oreilles qui vivent surtout à
l'attelage ça comme une immense choses
qui avancent qu'à une puissance
extraordinaire
et vous vous aimez ça au bout de vos
doigts et ça ça fait quand même un
grésillement qui part du bout des doigts
et qui vont jusqu'aux la tête et ça
c'est fantastique